les bureaux de vote sont ouverts depuis
8h et déjà plusieurs personnalités
politiques se sont rendus aux urnes la
première ministre elisabeth borne à vire
dans le calvados où elle est candidate
passage éclair à vire pour la cheffe du
gouvernement elisabeth bornes également
candidat dans le calvados le temps de
voter
je vous propose de regarder le chiffre
de la participation à midi il s'élève à
18 99 % c'est légèrement mieux que
dimanche dernier emmanuel macron prend
le temps lui serrer des mains de
s'adonner au rituel du baiser porte
bonheur sur le front de ce militant en
marche avant de glisser son bulletin
dans l'urne c'est la panique sur cette
plage de deauville
des centaines de personnes courent pour
se mettre à l'abri
c'est un coup de tonnerre daniel mâcon
wii conserve la majorité à l'assemblée
d'après nos projections lab mais perd la
majorité absolue toute petite majorité
relative pour le président de la
république surpris parfois paniqué
descente et de personnes tentent de fuir
le ventre ensemble tous les objets en
projectile la nuque et la première force
d'opposition avec 149 sièges en
troisième position et fait une surprise
et un coup de théâtre ce soir le
rassemblement national
c'est une situation totalement inattendu
absolument inouïe la déroute du parti
présidentiel est totale et une majorité
à villers sur mer un kitesurfeur a même
perdu la vie en étant projeté sur la
vitrine de ce restaurant elisabeth
bornes la première ministre serait élu
dans le calvados avec 52 3% et figures
de la majorité ont perdu dans leur
circonscription je veux parler de
christophe castaner dans les alpes de
haute provence le patron des députés de
la majorité n'est pas réélu et puis le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand un très prochain
d'emmanuel macron lui non plus n'est pas
réélu fin de la guerre me permettrait
d'avoir un mot pour eux un mot
évidemment d'amitié de solidarité ils
sont allés au combat dans une campagne
qui a été difficile dans un contexte
assez inédit avec un président qui a été
réélu avec une majorité avec une
inflation élevée trop élevé quel bon
débarras
d'avoir vu après monsieur blanc caire
éliminé dès le premier tour
douar éjecter les baigneurs castaner
[Applaudissements]
et l'injure yeuse montchanin ce
mélenchon a perdu son pari je veux aussi
voir que le rassemblement national a
fait un très gros score c'est je crois
le gagnons entre monsieur mélenchon à
marine le pen s'est malheureusement je
crois on le constate madame le pen qui
si l'on en croit les sondages à plus de
90 députés il a décidé d'envoyer un très
puissant groupe parlementaire de députés
rassemblement national à l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
qui devient ainsi un peu plus nationale
5e circonscription de l'ain où se
présentait damien abad ministre des
solidarités qui est visé par des
accusations de violence sexuelle selon
des résultats encore partiels il serait
élu à 58% les contaminations au kovy 19
sont en hausse santé publique france
recense plus de cinquante mille nouveaux
cas en sept jours une augmentation de
près de sept cent cinquante pour cent
des hospitalisations sont elles en
hausse avec près de 3000 personnes dont
330 et une admission soit critique c'est
une très bonne nouvelle mais vous voyez
que le travail sur le terrain ça pète